자 어떤 일을 마치는데 어른은
여덟명이 하면 10일이 걸리고 어린이
명이 하면 18일이 걸리 그 이건
결국 선생님이 그래 어른 한 명이
분만큼 일을 한다고 할 수도 있지만
이거를 우리가 전체 일을 생각을
해보자 그냥 만들어 먹는다고 생각을
해봐 그럼
얘는 으로 나눠 떨어져야 되겠지
그리고 180으로 나눠 떨어져야
되겠어요 안 떨어져야 되겠어요 그럼
최소 공부의 수를 구하면 전체 일은
720개 할 수 있어 없어 이해 됐어
여기까지 이해 됐니 자
그러면 어른은 한 명이 하루에 아홉
개씩
만들겠지
어린이는 어린 어 어린이는 얼마야네
개씩 만든다고 할 수 있어요 없어요
근데 어른 다섯 명과 그럼 45개씩
만들겠지 어린이 아홉명 36개씩
만들겠지
어 자 그러면 81 개씩 만들겠어요
안 만들겠어요 들어요 만들겠죠 그럼
720은 81로 나눠 봐 그럼 목숨
8이고 8.xx 이런 식으로 나오겠지
맞지
그럼 며칠이 걸리겠어
9일 이런 이런 것들 아니지 몇일만에
끝나느냐 자 200부터 600 사이에
수라고 했어요 그 숫자가 모두 다른
수는 몇 개일까요라고 했지
얘들아 200번 대가 있고요 300번
대가 있고 400번 대가 있고
500번 대가
있겠지 그럼 봐 내가이 0을 썼어요
아이 0을 썼든 안 썼던 여기는
뭐야 1 3 5 79를 쓸 수 있지
여기는 1 5 7 9 3을 이미
썼으니까
약 그다음에
12네 그래서 지금 얘기하는 거 맞지
자 그럼 봐요 2 1을 썼으면 개의
자연수 중에 두 개를 썼잖아 그럼
이때는 몇 개가 되겠어 여덟 개
이때는 몇 개가 되겠어요 2 3을
썼어도 여덟 개가 다 되겠어 안
되겠어 이해되니 그럼 이때는 8 *
5가 돼서 몇 개가 되겠어 40개가
되겠지 그럼 400번 때도 똑같이
40개가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 이때는
8 4 32고 이때도 32개가 되겠어
안 되겠어 그럼 모두 다 더하면 몇
개가
되겠어
140 4개라고 할 수 있겠습니다
어려운 문제
아니었었다 자 넘어가자 3번 문제
봅시다 어느 해에 3월 달력의
일부분입니다 같은 해 7월
22일은 무슨 요일인지 구하세요고
했어 다른 자세요 자 어느 3월
달력이라고 했지 근데 얘들아 봐 8
15 22일 그럼 결국 3월 22일은
금요일이라고 할 수 있어 없어 그럼
4월 21일 5월 22일 6월
22일 7월 22일을 생각하면
되겠지 자 그러면 여기는 3일이
지나야 되고 2일 3일 2일이 지나야
되잖아 근데 한 번에 다 할 수
있지만 10일이 지났다는 거 7로
나눴을 때 나머지가 3이지
는 세 개면 나머지가 같다 뭐 이렇게
정확히 얘기하면 그걸 모드라고 하거든
실로 나눴을 때 나머지가 3이다
알겠어 이걸 합동식이라고 해 어
도형에 합동이 있잖아 서로 겹치는 거
똑같은 걸 합동이 하잖아 수에도
합동인 거 나머지가 같은 걸 합동이
얘기를 해요 그럼 봐 그럼 더하기
3일이 지났지 그럼 답은
월
되겠습니다
됐어 자
4번요 자 설날에 가족들이 한 집에
모였 사촌 형제들은 모두 일곱 명씩
있었대 이렇게 맞지 그러면
여기가 늘어났어 여섯 번 늘어났지
그럼이 첫 번째를
동그라미라는 얘는 동그라미 더 12가
되겠어 안
되겠어 그러면은 나이 적은 동생의
내배가 동그라미 더기 12랑 같으니까
적은 아이는 동그라미 세개 차이가
12가 되겠지 그럼 동그라미는 4가
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼 여기가 몇
살이 되겠어 16살 여기는 14살
여기는 12살이 되겠지 답은 12살이
되겠 자 5번 조용 싸키 나무예요
그럼 이것은 위에서 본 바탕 그림에
이렇게 적어야 되는데 무엇을 값
최소의 값을 구하라고
했지 그럼 얘를 구할 때는 어떻게
하는 거냐면 우선 혼자 있는 애
여기는 무조건 3이 되겠어 안 되겠어
그리고 여기는 1이 되겠어요 안
되겠어 그리고 같은 수가 만난
곳 여기도 얼마가 되겠어 2가 된다고
할 수 있고 여기는 4라고 하면
되겠지 그리고 나머지 빈칸을 1이라고
해주면 돼요 그럼 7하고 3하고
6하고
아니다 5하고 2을 더하면 되겠어요
안 되겠어요 되겠죠 어 잠깐만 뭔가
이상한데 1하고 1하고 2하고 4하고
3하고 1하고 아 요거 1이구요
아 여기 1이어도
되잖아 만나도 여기이가 2이 하나가
있잖아
맞지 그럼
여기는 4가 되겠어 안 되겠어 그래서
16개가
되겠습니다 84 한 친구들은 틀렸어
왜 그런지 설명해 줄게 우선은이
안쪽에 있는 걸 생각을 해 봐 그러면
칸이네 칸이고 세 칸이는 3 곱하기
10인 건 알겠어 모르겠어 그럼
여기도 3 * 10이
되겠지 여기도 세 칸 아 두 칸네
칸이가 뭐야 3 곱하기 10이
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그래서 여기는
몇 개가 되겠어 90개가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 되겠지 자 그런
하나 더 생각해야돼 뭐가 있거 봐요
아니 아니 잘
봐 여기 있는 네모는 이미 세졌고
하지만 여기 있는 네모는 셌어요
안어요 셌어요 안 셌어요
안죠 여기 있는 네모 셌어요 안
셌어요 안 셌지 다른 데는 다 세겠지
여기가 뚫려 있으니까 이해 됐어 그럼
여기는 어떻게 되겠어 요거
하나가 2 * 2가 아니 3 * 3이
돼서 아홉 개가 되겠지 여기도 몇
개가 되겠어 아홉 개가 되겠지 그래서
90에서 18을
더해야
다 아이디어는 참 좋았는데 여기는
생각하지
못했었지네 이해
됐어 자 7번
보겠습니다 7번은 선생님이 거의
맞으라고 준 거지 얘들아 봐 흰색
바둑돌이 16개가 더 많으면 흰색
하나를 빼고 이렇게 묶어 주면 되겠지
그럼 여기서부터이 끝까지가 두 개씩
15 묶음이 되면 되고 여기 하나가
있으면 되잖아 그럼 2 * 15에
1을 더하면 되겠지
31번가
되겠습니다 헨젤은 집에서 돌아가는
길을 잃어버리지 않기 위해 집에서
숲속까지 일정한 간격으로 바닥에
빵조각을
두대 근데 빵 조각의 개수가 아니라
아주 친절히 빵조각 타이의 간격의
수가 나왔어 그럼 결국
25m 21개가 있지
85만 가니까 네모 분이 흘렀을
거잖아 그럼 얘를 5로 나눠
볼게 17이 되겠지 17로 나눠
주면은 13이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
그럼요 네모는 65가 되겠지 그럼
답은 몇
분
65분 자 루 날에 얘들아 이건 반복
마디는 레에서 끊어지는 거지 그러면은
여기 까지는 일곱 개고 여기도 일곱
개잖아 그럼 반복
마디는 개 14개가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 되겠지 여기까지
이해됐어요
20 23을 얼마로 나눠주면 되겠어
14로 나눠주면 되겠지 목 구한 사람
목 얼마 나왔어 144 그렇지
144가 되고요 나머지가 7이 되겠
그 일곱 번째니까
답은가
되겠습니다 하지 않기로
했잖아요 자
10번 1부터 540초 아지 적혀
있을 때 5가 적혀 있는 개수를
구하라고 했지 자 14일이라고 했던
사람은 5의 개수를 구한 거기 때문에
틀렸지 100번
때 200번 때 300번
때
400번대 500에서 540까지
자 그러면 여기는 19개 19개
19개 19개 개 왜냐면 55에
겹쳤나 근데 여기는 100의 자리에
5가 무조건 있으니까 41 개지 그건
19 곱하기
5에서 41을 더하면 되잖아
그럼 얘는 95 45 95에서 41을
더해주면 되겠죠 답은
되겠습니다 얘들아 여기까지는
얼마야
5050이지 근데 여기 있는 1을
여기다가 붙어 근데 여기 이미
100의 리에이 하나더 있을 거잖아
그럼는 5 모두 다 있다고 하면
50502 100개가 있겠어요
없겠어요 여기까지 이해됐어요 자
그리고
더하기
100이 이때는 하나 더 있겠지
이때는 두 개 있겠지 이때는 세 개
더 있겠지 해서 99개만큼 더
있겠어요
없겠어요 이해 됐어 그러면 여기서부터
여기까지는 얼마니 50에서 100을
빼
4천
얼마야
950이상 중에네 장 구르는 거잖아
근데 얘들아 여기 크기 순서대로 되어
있어
어 안 돼요 있지 헷갈릴 수 있으니까
이렇게 바꿔 주는 것이 더
좋겠죠 근데 두 자릿수 곱하기 두
자리가 우리가 맥스라고 하면
최대아웃풋 776 * 9도 생각할 수
있어요 없어요 그럼 얘는요
72 76
42 48하 63을 더했으니 111이
되겠네 그래서 8,3 52가 나오겠지
얘는 96에
54 조용해 97에 63
7884아서 누가 당첨 얘가 당첨이
자
그러면
최소값은 두 자리 곱하기 두 자리니까
반대라서 세 자리 곱하기 한 자리지
그럼 가장 적은 자리가 한 자리가
돼야 되고 678이 되겠죠 그럼 8
4 32 7 4
28 그 27 122가 되겠냐 안
되겠 그럼 문제에서는 더하라고 했지
그래서
1164 자 여기까지 점수
보자 관우가 영화를 보고 거래 비친
시계를 보았더니 영화가 시작할 때와
똑같은 모양이었는데 얘들아 거래 비친
시계랑
똑같으려나
시간이 돼야
돼요 근데 3시고 9시 사이에
봤으니까 12시간 차이는 아니겠지
그건 6시를
기준으로 140분이 그 얼마 분이라서
50분씩
50분씩 적어져서 5시 10분이
되겠고 많아져서 5시
아 6시 50분이 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 되겠죠 이해됐어요 아 이거를
잘못
얘기했다
실을 기준으로 이해 됐어 그래서
얘네들은 어떻게 되겠어 5시 10분
6시 50분이 답이
되고 축구공 한개를 사는데 주연이가
가지고 있는으로는 1700원
부족하 유준이가 가지고 있는 돈으로는
150원이
부족하 유빈이가 가지고 있는 돈은
10000원이 부족하 합하면 축구공
두 개사고 50원이 남는 거잖아네
이건 결국 그냥 간단한 방정식 학가
차의 배수 문제가 되겠지 다 더하면
동그라미 세 개인데 얘랑 얘랑 얘를
빼 줘야 되겠죠 그럼 얘를 더하면
4,950이 되겠어 안 되겠어 물론
더하기가 아니라 여기는 빼기가 돼야
되겠지 그럼 동그라미 두 개 더하기
50이 동그라미 하나 차이가
4,950 내려가고 50이 올라갔 어
얼마야 5,000원이 되겠지 그럼
주연이는 5천원보다 1700원이
부족하니까 3,300원이 되겠고요
그다음에는 3,1 50원이 되겠고
마지막으로는
3,600원이
되겠습니다 자
15번은 틀렸잖아
자 13번은 아니 15번은
얘들아 봐봐요 네모 모양과 똑같은 건
여기 있지 그 얘는 5인 거야 얘는
어디 있어 여기지 그럼 더하기 거야이
모양은 어디 있어요 여기 있어서 9가
되지 얘는 빼지 얘는 여기
있잖아 7이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
그럼 봐요이 모양은 어디 있어 3이
되겠지 얘는 더하기가 되겠고 얘는
4가 되겠지 얘는 더하기가 되겠어 안
되겠어
얘는 5지 얘는 빼기가 되겠고 얘는
8이 되겠죠 답은 4가
되겠습니다 자
16번 목과 나머지가 같은 수야
얘들아 그런데 중요한 거
나머지는
얼마까지 26까지 가능한 거 알아요
몰 그럼 얘를 검산 식으로 쓰면 27
* 동그라미 더하기 동그라미가 되겠지
그럼 얘는 28 곱하기 동그라미가
100보다 커야 되니까 동그라미는
4부터 26까지 되겠어요 안 되겠어
그건 수의 개수는 몇
개 23개가 되겠죠 자
그다음 17번 아수
별표에서 2는 1 2 근데 얘들아
봐라 1 1은 1 2 2는 4 3 3
9 4 4 16 5 5 25가
되겠지
조용
그러면
얘를
이렇게 정사각형이 있다고 해 봐 그럼
여기는 15 여기도 15라 하면
어디가 되겠어
여기가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 되겠지
그리고
여기는 이렇게 되는 거지 판는 거
지금 어딜가 그럼 얘 구하는 거야 안
구하는 거야 그럼 여기 위에 자리는
17 *
17이라는 29가 되겠지 그럼 칸이
내려가야 되는
거잖아
맞잖아 네 아니에요
아니에 잠깐만 1 2
맞지 3
5 잠깐 잠깐 아
여기구나 이렇게 되는
거지
맞잖아 자 3 23 봐봐 3
5아 맞아 맞아
맞아
맞지 그럼 얘는 어떻게 돼 280
19에서 14를 빼줘야 되겠지 오케이
5가 되겠습니다 자 그런데 얘들아
선생님게 실수한 거 같네 여기를
사라고 써야 되는데 너희들이 헷갈려서
요거 헷갈렸을 수도 있어 맞지 말도
안 돼 그 물어봤어야지 자 그러면
이거는 중복 정답으로 할게 알겠지
아니 이제 답이 맞아야 그지 얘만
봤을 수도
있잖아 여기를 안 봤을 수도 있잖아
그럼 15 17은 어디가 되겠어 잠깐
이거
치워놓고 여기가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
맞지 그럼 15 17을 구해야 되잖아
그 얘는 조금 더
어렵겠다 이렇게 내려가겠지 여기가
275가 되겠지 근데 17 * 17을
보니까 이렇게
작아졌죠 맞죠 그러면은
273 여기는
272 여기는 271이 되겠어 안
되겠어 그래서
27일도 정답이라
하겠습니다는
얘들아 이거는 그냥 방정식으로
풀까 처음에 1이
있었어 두 장씩 동그라미만
접었어요 집었어요 그런
다음에 세 장씩 집은
거는
70 99번을 집었 있지 왜 첫 번째
1은 시작했으니까 그 79에서
동그라미만큼 뺀 것이 얼마가 돼야 돼
200이 돼야 된다고 할 수 있어
없어 판 지 그럼 얘는 1+ 2 *
동그라미 이렇게 곱하면 얼마야
237이 되겠지 이렇게 곱하면 3
곱하기 동그라미 뺐더니 200이
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼
238 동그라미를 빼면 200이
된다고 할 수 있어요 없어요 그럼
동그라미는
얼마야 38이 되는 거잖아 그럼 결국
1에서 2씩 30 8번 집은 것이
되겠지 그래서 답은 77이
되겠습니다 아 얘들아 이거 봐라 1
1 + 2 1 + 2 + 3 1 +
2 + 3 + 4 1 + 2 + 3
+ 4 + 5지 그럼 결국
1에서 네모만 더해서
2023에
가까워져야 그럼 얘는요 가우스
덧셈으로 생각하면 네모 곱하기 네모
더하기 1이 23에 두 배가 되는
값을 찾아주면 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
맞지 자 이거는요
1부터에 어쨌든 두 자리 곱하기 두
자리가 되겠어 안 되겠어 그럼 얘는
60명 곱하기 60 몇이 되겠지
이해됐어요 그럼 만약에 1부터 6까지
구해
그래 1부터 6까지 구해보자 그럼
얘는
얼마야 63 곱하기 31이 되겠어 안
되겠어 62의 절반이 그럼
1953이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 물론
두 수만 연속해서 곱해 버리면
3800 얼마가 나오겠지 그럼 1부터
63까지 해주면 여기다가 63을
더하면
니까 2016이 되겠니 안 되겠니
이해 됐어 근데 2016은 63번째
홀수 번째 더한 거랑이 윗줄에 있는
거잖아 그럼 여기를 2016이 써
볼게 그럼 여기는 1 63이 되겠어
안 되겠어 근데 홀수 번째는 아래로
내려갈수록
작가죠 그럼요 옆에 있는 2017은
1 64가 되겠지 그럼 2018 은
여기가 되겠어 안 되겠어 여기는 2
63이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 여기는
17 아니다
19 20 21 22 23이 나왔어
안 나왔어 그럼 3 4 5 6 7이
되겠지 그건 65에서 7을 빼주면
얼마야 58이
되겠지 그래서 답은 일곱 번째
줄
[음악]
58번째음 20번
10번 자 20번도 읽으면 되죠
갯벌이 염전에 물이 흐르는 길이래
이거는
뭐야 오른쪽에 세 배만큼 물이 흐르는
거라고 할 수 있어요 없어요 그러면은
a 528 있잖아 이건 그냥 시계
계산 문제지
얘를 4로 나눠야
되겠지 그럼 132가 되겠지 그럼
여기는 얘 세 배니까 39 6만큼이
되겠어 안
되겠어 여기는 얘를 4로 나누면
얼마야 28이 되겠지 얘의 세 배가
되니까 84가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 자 그러면 여기는 132가
보이겠고 얘랑 얘를 더한 얼마가
보이는
거야 424 보이는 거지 여기는
그대로 84가 되는 거지 여기에 또
4로 나누면 여기는 33이 내려가고
여기는
99 106이 되는
거잖아 그래서 여기는 205가 되겠지
여기는 4로 나누면 아 3을 곱하면
318이지 그 21이 그럼 339
되겠고요 얘는요 63이 돼서 그대로
63이 그러면
1하고 3을 더하면 얼마가 돼요
372 되겠지 2번하고 4번을 더하면
28이 되는 거잖아 빼면
되겠지 답은
104l 자 21번은 거꾸 해결하기
문제잖아 선생님이 거꾸 해결하기는
어떻게 하라고
했어 이렇게 표를 그리라고 했었지
맞죠 그리고 그거 칠판 봐야지
갑을 어 그리고 72개가이거나 항상
똑같은
거라 자 그런데 여기에서 이제 이렇게
해놓고 문제를 읽어
보자 갑이 먼저
나눠줬어요 얘들아 을은 나눠줬어요 안
나눠줬어요 안 나눠 줬어 그 거꾸로
푸는 거야 자 병이 갑과 을에게 여덟
개를 적게 나눠
그럼 만약에 여덟 개를 더 주었다면
두 배가 된 거지 그럼 얘네들은
원래는 16개가 있었겠어
없었겠어 그럼 16개를 더하면 병은
40개가
있었겠죠 자 이번에는 갑이 나눠줬다
말이야 어 그러면은 얘는 몇 개야
여덟 개가 있었다면 두 배가 되는
거잖아 그 여기는 12개가 되겠고
24개가 되겠지 그럼 얘는 16에
개를 준 거고 를 주었다고 할 수가
있겠죠 그럼 얘는 36이 되겠습니다
그래서 답은 36개 12개
24개 자 5보다 크대 그럼 얘는
5.xx x 꼴이 되는 거지 어 근데
0을 모두 몇 번 쓰느냐고 물어봤어
그럼
얘들아 나는 이렇게 할래
5.0 xx 때가 있겠고
5.
x0 x 때가 있겠어요
없겠어요 물론 여기에 x 0이 아니면
되는
거잖아 그러면
여기에 0이 있을 수도 있고 1일
수도 있고 2일 수도 있고 3일 수도
있고 9일 수도 있겠죠 근데 0.
0일 때는 몇 개를 쓸 수 있어
아홉개를 쓸 수가 있겠지
이때는 를 쓸 수 있고 이때도 아홉
개 아홉 개가 되겠죠 그럼 잘 봐요
이때는 0이 두 개잖아 그래서
18개가 있겠고요 이때는 9가
아홉개가 있어서 9 곱하기 9가
되겠지 그럼 9가 개니까 99개가
되겠어 안 되겠어 자
그다음 0은 안 되고 1 2 3부터
9까지 있는 거잖아 근데 이때는 0이
못 들어가고 몇 개씩 개씩 있어요
없어요 그럼 얘는 9 * 9가 돼서
뭐가 되겠어 81이 되겠지 그럼 얘는
99 + 81이 되는
거잖아네 답은 180번이
되겠습니다 얘들아이
문제는 잘
봐요 이렇게 표로 그리는게 좀 더
편해
자 가영이가
있어요 효은이가
있어요
그리고 예리가
그런데 문제를 더 오래 걸렸다는게 더
오래 풀었다는 얘기잖아 그 이거는
같은 문제를 가지고 더 오래 걸린게
아니라 더 많이 풀었다는 얘기지
문제를 읽어보 그러면 걸린 시간을
보면
누가 제일 적어 예리가 가장
적지 그러면은 효근이는 예보다 10분
더 오래 걸렸고 그럼 가영이는
20만큼 풀겠어 안
풀겠어 이렇게 됐죠 자
그리고
1분의 양을
생각하면 누가 가장 적어요 가이가
적지 하지마 그다음 효근 는 한 문제
더 했지 예슬이는 두 문제 더
풀었으니까 더하기 3이 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 아
됐니 자 이제
보자 첫 번째 조건
효근이 아고 예슬이가 품 문제의
개수가 똑같다고 했잖아 그럼 얘랑
얘랑 곱해야 되지 그럼 동그라미
곱하기 우선 세모가 있겠고 동그라미가
있겠고 10 곱하기 세모가 있겠고
10이
있겠죠 이해
됐어이거나 예슬이가 큰 거니까
동그라미 곱하기 세모 더하기 3곱하기
동그라미나 서로
어떻겠어 같겠지 자 두 번째
가영이는 요만큼 풀었 아아 근데 몇
문제 더 풀었다 예술이나 효근이 다
열 문제를 더 풀었 아아 그럼
얘는 이렇게 식을 쓸 수 있어요
없어요 자 그러면 약분이 아니죠
소거된다 해야 돼 지워지는 거니까
약분을 1로 만들어질 수가 있는 거고
속어는 0이 되는 걸 얘기하는 거야
알겠어네
자 왜 너무
따진다고 그럼 얘는요 어떻게
되겠어 2 곱하기 동그라미에서 10
곱하기 세모를 빼면 얼마가 되겠어
10이 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 이렇게 지우면
얘는요 3 곱하기 아
이거는 이렇게 바꿔 볼까 20 *
세모는 3 곱하기 동그라미 더하기
10이 되겠지
얘들아 얘들아 여기에서 10 곱기
세무는 2 곱하기 동그라미 -
10이라고 할 수 있니 없니 그럼
20 *
세무는
어 아니지 얘 넘기고 얘 이쪽으로
넘겼으니까 - 20이라고 할 수 있어
없어 그럼 3 * 동그라미 더하기
10이나 4 곱하기 동그라미 빼
20이나 같으니까 동그라미는 얼마가
되겠어 30이 되겠어요
안 자 동그라미가 30이면 어 얘는
60이 그럼 세모는 5가 되겠어요 아
5가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
차 자 그런데 문제에서 뭐 물어봤어
형이잖아 그럼 시간은 50시간 안
맞죠 50분 동안 다섯 문제씩 푸른
거지 답은
제를 풀었다고 할 수
있겠습니다요 여섯 장의 숫자 카드 중
몇 장을 골라 한 번씩 사용하여 수를
만든대 근데 4하고 8이 이해야 되지
그럼 얘들아 우리 두 자릿 수에서는
몇 개가 있겠어 두 개가 있겠지 세
자릿 수에서는 48 땡 땡
48 8사 땡 땡 8사 이렇게
있겠지 그럼 이때는네 개네 개
들어가니까 여덟 가지가 되겠니 안
되겠니 이때는 0이 못 들어가니까
여섯 가지가
되겠지 14개가 되겠지 자네 자리일
때는
조용 이렇게 되겠지 그럼이 48을
84로 고쳐주면
되잖아 자 봅시다 너 뒤돌아보면
어떻게 된다고
했어요
자 4하고 8이 있어요 그럼 여기는네
개 세 개가 들어가니까 몇 개
12개가 되겠지 여기는 0이 못
들어가니까 3 * 3이 돼서 아홉개가
되겠지 황수 문제는 뭐야
집중력이 끝까지 포기하지 않으면
우리가 충분히 사용했던 공식만
활용하는 거잖아 그럼 이때는 몇 개야
60개가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼
얘랑 얘랑 얘랑 더 해야 되겠지
답은 76개가
되겠습니다 그렇게 어려운 거 아니라고
했었지 자
25번 1 * 2 + 2 * 3 +
3 * 4에서 100 *
101 까지를 계산하라 그럼
얘들아 이거는 1 * 2는 1하고
2하고 3을 곱하고 3으로서 있겠어
없겠어 그럼 2 *
3은 2 * 3 *
4에서 아니 - 1 * 2 * 3
하고 나누기 3을 해도 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 그럼 3 *
4는 3 * 4 * 5를 하고요 2
* 3 * 4를 하고 나누기 3을 할
수가 있겠어요 없겠어요 있겠어요 그럼
쭉 가서 100 * 101은 예주나
어떻게
되겠니
그러면 얘네들을 다 더하면
저요 이렇게 모두 사라지겠다 안
사라지겠죠 그럼 얘는 0이 돼 버리는
거잖아 그럼 남는 것은 얘밖에 없는
거지 그럼
얘는 100 * 10 * 102 나누
3이 되겠어 안 되겠어
그러면은 얘랑 얘랑 나눠지죠 아 이거
왜 왜 100이 일었어 100 맞지
그럼
3,400 * 101이 되겠니 안
되겠니 그럼 답은 3 4 3 4 0이
되겠습니다 그다음
26번 얘들아 이거는 문제를 잘 봐야
돼을 병정이 5로 열 문제씩 풀었다
근데 모두 일곱 문제를
맞췄다 맞아요 그럼 얘를 정답을
예상해야 되겠지 맞지
그러면 두 개씩 있는 걸 따져보자 얘
맞았다고 생각하고 얘도 맞았 이게
동그라미가 정답이라고 생각을 해 보자
이때는 x 이때는
동그라미 아 이따가 해보려고
동그라미 이건
모르지
동그라미 동그라미가 정답이라고 해 봐
그럼 얘는 맞았고 틀렸고 맞았고
맞았고 틀렸고 맞았고 틀렸고 틀렸고
맞았고 하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯이 되는
거잖아 그럼 얘는
결국 x 정답이고 x 정답일 수
있어요 없어요 자 이렇게 두고 아래를
보는 거야 하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯
일곱 개 병도 볼까 하나
둘 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 개 그럼 이제
끝났지 그 얘만 확인하면
되겠지 하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯
일곱
여덟 아홉
오케 자 우리 한번 거꾸로가 보자
맞지 자 23년
22년 21년 20년 19년 18년
17년 16년 대충이 정도 해볼까
응 자 이때는 월요일이라고 한번
해보자 1월 1일 그 이때 1월
1일은 일요일이 되겠냐 안 되겠 이때
1월 1일은 하루 전날이 되는
거잖아 토요일이 되겠어 안 되겠어
맞지네 자 이때는 1월 1일을
기준이야 얼마가
되겠어
어 예
목요일이지 왜냐면 이쪽 가면서
이해됐어요 1월 1일이 기준이 이때는
수요일
화요일 월요일이 되겠어
답은
2017년 자 잔디밭 깎는데 한
잔디의 넓이는 다른 잔디밭 두
배 이렇게 할 수 있어요 없어요 어
첫째 첫째 날에는 모든 농부들이 하루
종에 큰 잔디밭에 잔디만 깎았다 둘째
날에는 농부들이 같은 인원을 두
조씩나요 한 존은 하루 종에 큰
잔디밭을 가없고 다른 존은 작은
잔디밭을 깎았다 그거 큰 잔디밭은
모두 깎았네요 그럼
봐요 이만큼
남았겠지 요만큼
남았겠지 그러면 작은
잔디밭은 남아
있었대
이해됐어요 어떻게 할 수 있어 여기를
동그라미 두 개라 해주면 얘는
동그라미 하나고 여기도 동그라미
하나라고 할 수 있어요 없어요 있죠
그런데 이만큼고 얘하고 절대 같을
수가 있어요 없어요
없죠 이렇게 할 수 있어요 세 개 세
개니까 여기는 하나가 되겠냐 안
되겠지 이해
됐어 이렇게 되는
거잖아 이해 됐어 하루 종일네 개를
했고 절반이 하루 종일 두 개 두
개를 했어요 안
했어요
맞지 그럼 모두 몇 명이
되겠어요 뭐야 셋째 날에는 얘가 하루
종일
깎은 거지 이해됐어요
그러면 농구는 모두 몇 명이었을
요라고
했어 그럼 얘는 몇
명네 명이라
아
자 예를 봅시다 자 나는 이거 이렇게
풀래 1층
2층 3층 층이지 자 무조건 틀릴리가
없는 방법을 알려
줄게요 어 4층 있는
거지 얘 제일 아래층부터 생각을
해보자 알겠지 그럼 바탕 그림
그리기로 했어
기억나니 자 여기 세 개가 있고요 붕
떠 있지는 않았을 거잖아 여기 하나가
있겠어요 없겠어요 또 여기도 있겠어요
없겠어요 있겠죠 그리고
원투쓰 이렇게 있겠 요렇게 아래
있겠어 없겠어 있겠죠 자 그다음에
여기를 보면은 하나도 없어지지
않았잖아 그럼 곱하기 2가 되겠어 안
되겠어 되겠지 이해 됐니 자 그다음
여기를 보면은 요만 안에 하나랑 요만
안에 하나가 생기네요 그죠 위에는
렇게 하나 생기겠어 안 생기겠어
생기겠지 자 그다음 한 개 한 개 한
개 한
개 세 개
세 개 두 개 세 개 세 개 두
개 한 개 한 개 두 개 두 개 두
개 두 개 한 개 이거 다 더하면
답이
되겠습니다 마지막 문제니까 더 해
봅시다 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 19 20 21 22 24 24
25 26 20 17 54 하나 둘
셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉 열
11 12 13 14 왜 우리 이렇게
멍청한 짓을 하고
있지 어쨌든 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19
[음악]
20 더 12
3 뭐야 이것도
100이야
자 정의용사 종료를 구출하기 해서
하늘에서 낙선을 가고 60m 아래로
총소 2m 속력 그럼
얘들아 여기서부터 여기까지 내려가는게
몇 초 걸려 30초 30초 걸리지
그럼
악당은 30초
동안
150m만큼
도망갔지
그런데 자동차를
타려면 몇 미터를 더 가야 돼
250m 더 가야
되지 그럼 250m 가는 동안은 몇
초가
걸리겠어 50초가
걸리겠지 이거는 얘들아 자동 타기
전에 잡는 거니까 얘는 필요 있어요
없어요 없죠 그럼 결국 얘는 어떻게
해야 돼 50초
동안 몇 미터를 가야
돼요 400m 가면 되겠어요 안
되겠어요
그래서
100m 4분의 50초가 걸리겠어 안
걸리겠어 그래서
12와
맞지 12. 5가 되나
잠깐 12.
5초